après ce point neige on parle sport à
présent le Comité Départemental
Olympique qui a décidé de reconduire son
président pour un nouveau mandat de 4
ans Jean-Lou le plat vous avez donc été
reconduit dans vos fonctions à quoi va
vous servir ce nouveau mandat écoutez le
mandat il est il est vaste puisque par
définition vous le savez sans doute on a
une mission général qui est extrêmement
large nous devons non seulement
représenter tous les sports auprès des
pouvoirs public il faut quand même se
souvenir que les ivelines sont le plus
grand département franilien en terme de
pratiquant sportifs plus de 400000 c'est
quand même important nous avons plus de
60 comités qui nous sont attachés et
donc dans les 4 ans qui vont venir on a
un très très gros programme à remplir en
matière de représentation du sport en
matière de formation d'élus de bénévoles
de professionnels on doit assurer toute
la promotion du sport hein à travers des
événems cels de qualité quel que la
soiré olympique a vue à Versailles et
qui aura lieu encore chaque année les
foulées olympiques on doit également
former je vous l'ai dit et puis on doit
aussi participer à à l'attribution des
subventions du CND ça c'est peut-être un
peu moins connu mais j'en profite du
c'est le comité c'est le Centre national
du développement du sport qui finance
les actions des comités sportifs
départementaux et des clubs et vous le
savez bien malheureusement sans argent
aujourd'hui on a un petit peu du mal à
subsist c'est V quelquesun des missions
qui concernent ledos on va les détailler
un petit peu plus mais auparavant juste
ca fait
ans que vous êtes en fonction ça faisait
10 ans précisément parce que j'avais
fait déjà un demimandat après mon
prédécesseur Pierre vaagou et qure et
deux mandat demand plein ça fait donc 10
ans j'avais fait déjà une année en tant
que responsable de la formation et après
ces 10 ans vous vous avez le sentiment
de ne pas avoir terminé le travail pour
repartir encore pour 4 ans
supplémentaires on na jamais fini vous
savez on est dans les pas les tras de
ses prédécesseurs et nous-même nous
devons propager l'héritage et et trouver
de nouveaux membres de nouveaux
commissaires de nouveaux administrateurs
pour continuer la tâche qui est immense
comme je vous le signaler et surtout
promouvoir le sport auprès des plus
jeunes c'est important véritablement que
ces jeunes s'impliquent et fassent du
sport quelle que soit la discipline
c'est très important effectivement que
les jeunes dès leur plus jeune
âge fassent des actions sportifes en
milieu scolaire avec l'aide de leur
famille normalement et puis avec l'aide
des instances publiques qui normalement
devraient leur mettre le pied érier mais
vous savez là il y a aussi l'aide des
clubs des comités je crois que c'est
indispensable tous les clubs se portent
bien dans le département quel que soient
les disciplines si onit petit état des
lieux rapides oui on peut dire que le
sport départemental Dans les vines se
porte bien il y a quand même de de bons
clubs de grands clubs de de de bons
comités beaucoup de membres je vous l'ai
dit 400000 licenciers pratiquants ça
compte on est le premier département et
puis je crois qu'on est un terrain ou un
Terrero c'est comme vous voulez de de
formation de bonne éducation sportive
dont d'ailleurs quelquefois d'autres
clubs extérieur au département profitent
à plus long terme parce que
effectivement à un moment donné et
justement il y a certains clubs qui s'en
plaignent on a reçu plusieurs
responsables de clubs he sur ce plateau
depuis depuis a des années c'est
toujours le même discours que que l'on
entend le département forme leurs club
sont formateurs mais au bout d'un moment
vous l'avez dit aussi tout à l'heure il
manque de l'argent pour les faire rester
pour développer un club au niveau
national également il n'y a pas de
grands club dans le département qui
rayonne sur la la scène nationale voir
international même non pas vraiment on
mettra bien sûr le parisintgermain de
côté qui est un club professionnel
complètement
indépendant est financ maintenant on
sait comment plus mais c'est vrai qu'il
y a pas de club très très important de
niveau national bon vous avez des clubs
de football je pense à eux comme le
poissi ou le FC Manoi mais qui subsiste
gentiment je pas dire difficilement mais
sans plus parce que effectivement je
connais un peu les chiffres ils sont pas
toujours aidés comme il faudrait par des
organismes officiels ou des collectivité
territoriale mais vous regrettez ça
justement qu'il n'y ait pas de grands
club sportifs dans dans le département
oui je le regrette parce qu'à partir du
moment où on a terrain de formation où
il y a beaucoup de jeunes qui sont bons
qui sont de qualité je trouve ça un
petit peu dommage qu'à un moment donné
les clubs du départ artement ne profite
pas de ces jeunes talents qui éclos et
qui vont progresser ailleurs je trouve
ça dommage donc il faudrait que les
pouvoirs publics les agglomérations les
communes la Région le Département
interviennent je crois vous tapez en
plein dans la dans la bonne cible c'est
que demain effectivement le sport
départemental devra être le fruit d'une
collaboration entre tous les acteurs du
mouvement sportif mais également tous
les territoires effectivement le Conseil
général les communautés d'aggloméraation
est de commune les communes et voilà ça
peut pas se passer autrement ces
différents champions tout même ils
existent dans ce département il y a
quelques quelques noms qui qui
ressortent et vous les récompensez
d'ailleurs régulièrement ça fait aussi
partie des des attributions du GS pour
promouvoir ce sport tout à fait chaque
année lors de la soirée olympique elle
avait lieu il y a peu fin janvier à
versaill nous avons récompensé
effectivement tous les gens toutes les
personnes qui méritent effectivement
d'être comprensé distingu ce sont des
sportifs bien sûr ce sont des éducateurs
ce sont des dirigeants ce sont des juges
arbitres ce sont des bénévoles et puis
des gens qui rayonnent un petit peu sur
le plan départemental ement de cette
cérémonie quels sont les noms qui vous
viennent en tête lorsqu'on évoque le
département des ivelines sur ces
champions qui ont été formés et qui font
parler du département aussi à l'étranger
écoutez à tout hasard Bruce Guillard en
en esrime par exemple mais il y en a
d'autres il y a aussi les sports
paralympiques il font parler comme
d'antqueta un espoir qui va venir
probablement sur la scène nous
l'espérons peut-être pour les jeux
paralympiqu de Rio je veux parler de
Johan killou qui est un tennisman qui
opère à
rouiller la clairrière et qui est
vraiment un espoir du du sport
paralympique non c'est un cï que vous
aviez cité hein donc pour lea
Saint-Quentin l'entente l'athlétique
c'est c'est de l'athlétisme vous l'avez
bien compris les Jeux paralympiques par
exemple ça aussi c'est une bonne vitrine
pour le département avec nantonin kï les
Jeux paralympiques les sports handicapés
justement c'est quelque chose que vous
développez avec le Comité Départemental
Olympique vous intervenez ça fait partie
de vos missions alors ça fait partie de
nos missions mais il faut dire que nous
avons encore une action importante à
mener dans ce domaine aussi bien auprès
d'andis sport que du sport dit adapté et
là je crois que son le département il y
a quand même beaucoup de champions
paralympique qui mérit d'être aidés
vraiment par le Glos et chaque fois
qu'on le peut on le fait on a des
actions nous ça fera partie de vos
missions pour les pour ce nouveau mand
déjà dans nos missions ça sera encore
dans nos missions et plus que jamais
votre priorité pour ce nouveau mandat
pour en revenir à cette élection qui qui
a permis de vous reconduire une nouvelle
fois pour un nouveau mandat de 4 ans
écoutez je crois qu'il y a beaucoup
d'actions spécifi vous avez parlé duis
sport du sport adapté il y a les jeunes
il faut que vraiment les jeunes
pratiquent le sport les femmes on en a
pas parlé encore les femmes la pratique
sportive féminine et l'accès au
responsabilité nous sommes très heureux
d' signaler que nous avons six femmes
d'orénavant dans notre comité nous n'en
avions aucune il y a une dizaine
d'années voyez il y a une progression
mais je crois qu'il font encore pour ce
domain là pour terminer vous êtes
heureux aujourd'hui de votre fonction
quand vous êtes arrivé au tout début
c'était un petit peu par hasard c'est ce
que j'ai cru lire dans la presse en 2003
vous vous a j' approché par des
personnes qui n'avaient plus de
président au ils m'ont dit bah écoute il
nous fut un président tu pourrais pas
devenir ce président là et le soir
j'étais c'est un peu par hasard
effectivement je suis devenu président
et aujourd'hui pas de l'assitude non non
non parce que j'aime ce que je fais
j'adore ça donc voilà je suis très
heureux dans dans cette fonction merci
Jean-Lou le plat d'être venu sur ce
plateau président pour quatre nouvelles
années du Comité olympique des zblines
nous en parlions hier en plateau
l'accord de compétitivité qui va rentrer
en vigueur au sein de Renault un accord
signé ce matin ce mercredi matin par les
principaux syndicats du groupe et la
direction ce qui change les conséquences
également dans le département pour les
sites yvelinois de fin pour la
production de Guy en cours pour
l'ingénierie avec ce reportage
d'antthony rche et puis juste après nous
parlons de l'action de l'association
Espoir à chernoby basée à voisin
bretonnais l'accord est historique pour
la première fois une entreprise
industrielle française Renault signe un
texte global pour faire face à la crise
signé par trois organisations syndicales
la CFDT CFE CGC et Force Ouvrière ce
plan de compétitivité permettra selon la
direction de faire 400 million d'euros
d'économie par an soit 300 € en moyenne
par véhicule la productivité repartira à
la hausse des avril prochain 710000
véhicules seront produits par an France
dont 80000 des constructeurs partenaires
Nissan et peut-être d'emler les usines
seront ainsi chargées à 85 % contre 65 %
aujourd'hui encore faudra-t-il vendre
dans un marché de l'automobile plus que
morose on est en train de revoir toute
notre gamme on lance le véhicule
électrique actuellement on a lancé des
véhicules certes symboliques mais qui
montrent bien la volonté de Renault
d'innover parce que comme le la tzy par
exemple et donc on a besoin de d'innover
on a besoin de conserver les les
activités à forte valeur ajoutée et
notamment au niveau de l'ingéerie pour
être à nouveau compétitif Renault
supprimera 7500 postes net d'emploi
d'ici à 2016 les salaires seront gelés
en 2013 et les ouvriers d'usine comme
Flin verront leur temps de travail
passer de 32h à 35h en contrepartie la
firme s'engage à ne fermer aucun site ni
recourir à des plans sociaux